I suspect it might be for secrets you
keep the fourth and final season of 13
reasons why how are you feeling about
saying goodbye to the show - clay Jensen
I mean that character has been such a
big part of your life for so long
it's weird I mean I'm very excited for
the season to come out I'm happy because
I feel like is something that people can
look forward to watching or having
during this time because I think any
sort of you know a lot of stuffs on sand
so right now so I'm excited that it can
come out it's strange it's always a
staple of my year I always know that
it's in the last four years I've always
been like okay I'm gonna go spend six or
seven months in the Bay Area and the
show's gonna come out this year too and
I'm a Prez and all this stuff and this
is the last time that it's really
strange to not have that to sort of look
forward to and it definitely makes you
miss it even more I'm just excited and
it's the right time running the show in
the terms that we want to and I feel
like we're getting you were giving a
send-off for these characters and the
one that is - served and know it's it's
emotional but I'm mainly just excited
you had previously told me that you
really wanted to dive into clays mental
health and that is obviously a huge
topic this season yes what was that like
for you to play
it was definitely important for me
because we've seen with clay since
season one
there's so much going on inside of him
you know what is it how do you pinpoint
it how'd you label it how much is
actually effective how deep does it go
like I had all these questions and I
feel like it's perfect that in season
four that clay is seeing dr. Elman
because dr. Elman has been name-drop
since episode two of the show from
season one so i feel like it's it's just
the perfect way to help tell clay story
in the final season and it feels very
rounded I don't know why I did that but
you know what you know around is but I
think is really important to me because
you can't just let that go unnoticed or
just not talked about I'm glad that
season four is sort of what it is is the
deep dive into into clays mine yeah
well as you were sort of reading the
scripts what was your reaction and how
do you feel about where clay and up I
don't talk too much about where clay
ends up cuz I want to leave it up to you
know I don't be able to know where clans
but I like to hope that he ends up you
know overcoming most of the struggles I
think everyone wants clay to overcome
the struggles that he's gone through
since the beginning of the show and for
all these characters I think there are
so many moments I'm like oh we're going
there like we are going to that spot of
clays mom you're going to that kind of
thought that you can have or this sort
of thing that you could do that we
couldn't imagine clay doing there's a
lot of those moments this season that
were done really well to me and there's
some things that I wanted to see happen
and they happen exactly that way then
they can't get into specifics about but
there are a lot of conversations with
Brian before the season about things
that I feel like we should see with clay
and then lo and behold there they are in
a script later so it definitely felt
like a real collaboration with Brian
this year on a lot of the storytelling
of them of clay is there anything
looking back that you would have changed
about clays journey I mean to help him
out for sure I mean I know for
storytelling purposes no but for you
know for clay I changed everything you
know I changed I mean but the struggles
that clay goes through I mean people
deal with the stuff in their lives all
the time and I think that clay
ultimately has become a stronger better
sort of person over and he's learned so
much and learned so many lessons and the
person that he does and doesn't want to
be that I think those really important
for clay to grow and hopefully be any
sort of step closer to man he like
really truly wants to be I wouldn't
change a thing because I think also you
know in season one all clay wanted to be
you wanted to be a hero and that has
been a downfall of his time and time
again on the show that's all you wanted
for Hannah he wanted to be positive
influence for her and to be that person
so bad for so many people along the way
and I think that clay does end up being
that for certain people on this show by
the end and I think it's great to
explore that and tend to see that all
sort of wrapped up in the end it's
really important there's just some
poetic some real poetic things in the
writing at the end of the show that I'm
very happy about is there room for a
possible spin-off in the future
I have no I wouldn't even begin to
imagine what it would be but I have no
idea would you play clay Jensen again in
some capacity of that word well clay
Jensen be around
after the show no I don't know I forget
I forget I can't remember the spit so
long
[Music]
do you have a message to the fans after
they watch these final episodes for
people that have stuck with the show and
the show has meant something to them and
that has been a positive influence on
them I really hope that they feel the
way that we do in making the season and
that we see these characters at least
their journeys in high school you know
complete I hope that everyone feels
rewarded enough in the end and feels
like they got the closure they needed
with these characters cuz that's what
the season is it's just a good closure
with these characters you know it's just
to finish a story that we started and
it's done really well and I hope
everyone feels the same I think there's
a lot of there's a real positive message
in the end of the season in the end of
the last season and I hope that it
resonates with people and that everyone
feels fulfilled and and uplifted
[Music]